you
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to a final Reuters form of the
year it's hard to believe that the years
over already but I'm glad to see that a
few of you were able to make it out for
our seventh panel tonight's topic is Big
Brother meets big business the future of
civil liberties in an unsafe world and I
know seven six debates have been
fabulous but I've saved the best for
last I'm glad you're all here I want to
also congratulate my class the students
of the Reuters florham have published
they've launched their issue of the
Reuters form journal and next year when
you all come back you're invited to pick
up a copy these are preview copy if you
don't have enough to to pass out to
everyone but I want to congratulate the
students and also remind those students
who have to take to the mic tonight but
this is your last chance make it to the
mic before the night is over I'm going
to introduce our moderator who will be
introducing the rest of our panel but
before I do that I do want to thank you
all for your loyal attendance this
semester and invite you back in January
2003 I am told we will have another
Reuters forum for you tonight so we have
a standing moderator I or I guess Bob's
been here four years at least and he's
always a favorite so it's another reason
why I've saved him for last Bob Kutner
is founder and co-editor of The American
Prospect he's a prolific writer I'm sure
you've seen his byline in many
publications including Business Week and
the Boston Globe New Republic and his
book everything for sale which was in
1997 named winner of the Sydney helmet
award that was a book that for many
years I've recommended that you read and
it's still worth reading so without
taking any more of tonight's time I am
going to turn the proceedings over to
Bob Kutner
well we we have been doing a little dry
run and in the green room as it work and
I think you're in for a treat maybe a
treat makes it sound frivolous because
this is such a weighty topic Big Brother
meets big business the future of civil
liberties in an unsafe world what could
that mean well I think since sep tember
11 and even before September 11 we've
had the intersection of several
unsettling trends this is a country
whose first national motto was don't
tread on me this is a very
liberty-loving country liberals and
conservatives don't agree on very much
but one thing they agree on is that they
don't like big brother and a big brother
these days that comes both in the form
of the public sector and in the form of
the private sector all kinds of new
technologies allow the creation of
databases that have commercial purposes
that go beyond the purpose for which the
data was collected and the issue of how
we safeguard our privacy from the misuse
of medical databases or financial
databases or credit databases has been
lurking for 20 or 30 years and there was
a spate of consumer legislation in the
70s designed to protect against the
misuse of data and there really has not
been much consumer legislation since
then because regulation is out of
fashion so the assault on privacy by
business is one set of issues but then
of course if you look at terrorism that
set of concerns sometimes seems like a
mere nuisance compared to the set of
concerns that having
have to do with how you reconcile your
prior your liberty as an American with
your security as an American and after
September 11th happened we at the
American Prospect agonized about how
does a liberal a self-consciously
liberal magazine address this set of
concerns and we ended up with a with a
special issue called defending an open
society that's the challenge how do you
value what is uniquely American that we
are more open than most societies when
the very security of the society is
under assault how do you square that
circle and of course business and
government come together in the
development of surveillance technologies
the CIA investing almost as a venture
capitalist in Silicon Valley for
purposes of making us more secure in a
way that strikes some people as making
us less free that's the subject of
tonight's panel and we really have three
quite extraordinary people to begin the
discussion Jeff Wharton is a man with a
distinguished record in many facets of
real estate and in june 2001 he became
managing director for the World Trade
Center so he has lived this in a very
deeply personal way Jay Lieberman is the
executive director of the Center for
Democracy and technology probably the
leading civil libertarian in the field
of how you reconcile an Internet Society
with a free society and Ira Jackson is
the director and faculty chair of the
Center for business and government at
Harvard's Kennedy School before that was
a senior executive of Bank Boston and
has served in a variety of government
and private sector posts
and judging by the little preview that
we gave each other there's going to be a
very interesting discussion so to begin
Jeff warden good evening as the
introduction said we preview what we
were going to say and based upon that i
want to i'm taking my prepared remarks
them and put them over here and if
you'll indulge me let me explain to you
why I'm here and let me see if I can
help frame the issue for the nice
discussion I think I'm here because I
was one of the people who was in the
trade center on 911 I'm one of four
people who survived being in that
restaurant and windows in the world of
the morning of the attack and so I've
lived through the experience of that day
in the horror of the day and struggle
with the issues before nine eleven of
how to provide a secure environment with
all the civil liberties issues and
struggle with it to this day and you
know when we did this as a month ago at
Reuters you know I said that if we were
doing this seven or a year ago and Tom
Friedman were here we were talking about
his theory that there are no two
countries in the world have McDonald's
that are ever at war with each other and
we brought about globalization and and
all the benefits of an integrated world
you know that was getting smaller all
the time and in the joys and the
benefits of Technology and a year later
you know when we have an asymmetrical
war and a low-tech war where we have
human bombs the conversation is very
different and let me see if I can give
you some context and bring you up to
today and help frame the issue the first
time that we face state-sponsored
terrorism this country and affected how
we lived in particularly real estate was
during the Gulf War and the buildings
that that I was responsible for managing
our response was to seal the buildings
to put to use dogs in the perimeters and
to control access and a very regulated
basis what was interesting is as the war
ended in the threat receded all of our
tenants ask that we reduce the security
totally and remove
the obstacles to make the building's
transparent to them which we did the
next time I faced it was a 96 when a
company bought Rockefeller Center and
that and I was a managing partner of
that venture and responsible for its
operations and for security and looked
at the same kinds of issues we we were a
target you know but not I didn't think
of it in terms of terrorism as such but
more in terms of street crimes and and
other issues that affect people and we
had a very transparent and open
environment except we also had 180
cameras monitoring the environment and
we did provide security for 150,000
people who are guests at the Christmas
tree and we did provide a del u system
lest you worried somebody try to burn
the tree down to put out the fire but
most of what we did was again provide a
high degree of transparency for the
sense for the center because people had
told us but that's what they wanted they
were prepared to being less secure
environment to have the transparency and
in the end remember tell you I I was
also a commuter to Germany I went every
other week for two and a half years to
involve us on the project one in Berlin
and one in Frankfurt and then we used
turnstiles as a way of regulating access
but again it was a very transparent
system so let me bring you up to june of
this year where the contract was signed
to privatize that the trade center and
to turn it over to private hands in part
of that process is really very
interesting I was allowed to read but
not take notes on or remove a security
assessment that was done after the 93
bombing and what the assessment really
the premise of it was is that people who
would wish us harm your ill and what
harm us are really afraid to identify
themselves so if you provide a system
where you screen people going into the
building you provide a high level of
security and the system that was evolved
at significant cost was a serial
embassies I'm sure you've seen things
like this he used things like this
there's an identity card that was issued
with my photograph on the front and a
bar code on the back and there was
series of turnstiles in the trade
you came in and you swiped your card
through when you allow access to the
building let me tell you let me explain
to when it was given to me they gave me
a gift of a wallet so you could take the
card you put it in the wallet you go to
the turnstile the place on turnstile you
walk in the building everybody had to be
photographed everybody had to walk in
everybody had to have this he put in a
while at you walk in and that that's how
security was provided now people were a
lot of people very offended they had
have their pictures taken and how to
have a card but the truth is you know
there's an illusion of safety and the
premise of it and my but I think we talk
about is people felt if you had your
photograph taken and you put it on a
card chances are you were not going to
do harm to the building or its occupants
I don't know about you but I found that
somewhat preposterous and and I said to
people that if you look at the world we
live in where people elsewhere in the
world were prepared to give up their
life to to cause harm I didn't
understand why our oceans and our board
has protected us from that risk and so
unlike some of the theoretical things we
discussed I had the practical
responsibility of providing security for
50,000 people and the people in that
building on that day and the real world
and so we started to explore the issue
and I explored it with somebody who
became dear to me who is who lost his
life on that morning his name is John
O'Neill who was a leading terrorist
expert in the FBI and probably only
person in the FBI who attract Osama bin
Laden and what he said to me as we as we
built up to the to the closing and the
transfer of control from the port
authority to private ownership is
anybody who believes that this country
is not at risk for to terrorism is
living in a fool's paradise and anybody
who doesn't understand that buildings
such as the World Trade Center are
terrorist targets is delusional and the
only way we get protected is provide
real security and that means that we
have to address some of the issues of
people being permitting themselves to be
inconvenienced and to be screened in a
way that we can provide meaningful
protection to people who are resident in
that building and to provide a cordon
around it with all the issues that are
attended to doing that it is and it we
started to explore it and I'm very
interested then wanted to participate
the panel to understand some of the
issues because we never finished the
conversation we're trying to do it now
is rebuild this in it but we didn't
finish the conversation on that day what
we did think about was the more we
wanted to provide a secure environment
the more we had to invade people's
privacy I mean the card that I showed
you has a bar code on it once you walk
in I am now known to the people in the
building and they now have whatever
information they have on my coming and
going what's interesting the tenants
were willing to tolerate a card which
which allowed them to enter the building
but they would not tolerate a card that
lad that had to be swipe to exit the
building which means you could walk in
the building you could spend a day a
week of the month there do whatever you
want to do and nobody knew if you ever
left it we just think about people were
not prepared to tolerate that so we had
a system that was basically gave the
impression of deterrence and let me tell
what it meant to me I thought about this
last night have not occurred to me it
made people who are like everybody in
this room or hope everybody in this room
people who you know who were not a
threat to the building feel that they
were security but there was nobody who
was a threat who felt insecure from the
system because they know what we know
they were prepared to give their lives
up so having the picture was a good
thing to do it wasn't a bad thing to do
so everybody walked in feeling look
isn't this wonderful we have the system
which was costing us 16 million dollars
a year that was providing security for
nobody so we started thinking about
things do you now have for example a
fingerprint so that we could identify
the person and immediately run it
through you know high-speed computers to
identify we know who was entering the
building do you use an iris scan which
is as good as a fingerprint so that you
can do the same thing in a way that
people think is less intrusive do you
use photography such as the they were
using at the Super Bowl where you get
scanned an image that images also run
through a system all these issues
started to come to the forefront with
all of the issues that our panelists I
think are better equipped to discuss
than I am but we're very troubling and
the other issue was who did we think we
were screening on those days the issue
that we had to face was whether or not
we will run now inadvertently profile
people in a way that was just is just
unacceptable and repugnant to all of us
but in a way that the system may have
operated in calling out people who may
be perceived perceived to have been a
risk to the building now we built we did
this leading up to the you know the
events of the eleventh of September and
I suspect we're all here because that
day changed everybody's lives and their
perceptions and and what would be
interesting to me to get out of evening
for myself is how much people are
prepared to tolerate some intrusion and
intervenes in their lives to provide a
higher level of safety and security in
buildings now as the physical
environment we have gone through an
interesting process we have we have work
with security consultants on the threat
assessment some based upon the mere
ability in Oklahoma some based on the
Trade Center some base and other
incident we have engaged the University
of Illinois to do for us a comprehensive
review of what they've learned including
people who are very much involved in
Israel have analyzed 300 attacks or
3,000 attacks on buildings to understand
how a building performs in that incident
and what I wanted to just without
frightening but but to frame the issue
in a way that I think is real the good
news and I mean this in an objective
sense not not not any other way the good
news of the 11th in September's the
attack was high in the building which
meant ninety percent of people below
that building were able to escape
because the the damage and the insults
the building was involved in most of the
incidents occur around the world on the
bottom of the building much different
issue much different threat in some ways
a lot more horrific in terms of
you know loss of life and in people's
conditions we can solve some of those
problems to make a building more secure
from that at a financial cost based upon
seven world trade center which we're now
in the process of rebuilding the
groundbreaking the actual story
construction was this morning we are
studying things you can do to hard in
the building to provide more secure AXA
ting all these issues and the course is
real we're estimating it's somewhere
between 10 and 15 million dollars to a
building about a million and a half feet
it means a dollar foot rent it means a
tenant coming has to pay a premium for a
building which is safer and more secure
not perfect safer and more secure this
is to me you know I say my wife last
night it's like people saying before you
put seat belts in cars you know if I
drive safely and I Drive a big nut car
what do i need this well it's more
expensive and it's it's a fee no it's
physically intrusive I have to I have to
strap myself in the answer is a society
do we want to pay the cost to provide a
more safe environment do want itself the
inconvenience of time and as I hope our
panels explore are we prepared to give
up some degree of our personal liberties
to allow people who are trying to
provide a safe and secure environment
enough information to secure the
building that's what we struggle with
before the 11 and that's what I have
struggle with every day since then to be
able to do it and the question is
whether or not this is commercially
feasible where the tenants will tolerate
it well the people will in the building
will feel safe and secure I think it's
something we don't know I just leave you
with one thought before I turn it over I
was watching CNN on the treadmill this
morning and the first reports out of
Israel were of that awful attack that
occurred last night and the thing that
just absolutely has upset me all day was
the reporter said people felt safe and
secure because they were in the third
floor of a building and the attacks to
this point had always been on the first
floor of a building so here you are in a
country that has suffered insult after
insult attack after attack and in that
culture people had made themselves feel
emotionally if I'm not on the first
floor I'm not at risk and what this
morning told me was what
the 11th in September told me is that
you are at risk in this world wherever
you are until we root the problem out
and until from my point of view we're
prepared to accept the cost in terms of
our civil liberties and the course of
doing it we are we are being delusional
to ourselves and for my vote on this I
would err on the side of providing a
more safe and secure environment and try
and trust ourselves and our people and
our heritage to protect ourselves
against the intrusions on our liberties
so thank you thank you our next speaker
is IRA Jackson thanks Bob and thank you
Jeff let me begin with just some
observations and then move to some
recommendations or at least some
suggested action steps that I think we
need to take as a society first to pick
up where Jeff left off I think
undeniably 911 changed everything just
changed everything the world is
different and will never be the same
Pandora's Box is open widely on the
issues that we're addressing tonight so
I think its timely and appropriate to
stop SS recalibrates some traditional
and conventional assumptions about
privacy the need for integrated data
collection and analysis security freedom
and even the future of capitalism as we
know it secondly while 911 accelerates
change and precludes putting the genie
back in the bottle it's worth reflecting
the changes were well underway before
911 that should have forced a greater
national discussion about security
vulnerabilities and threats to privacy
it seems to me we really didn't focus
adequately as a society on these trends
before and that it would be a major
mistake if we fail to address them
forthrightly now third nobody should be
intimidated into silence or endlessly
defer to experts on this subject if war
is too important to be left to the
generals than a war on terrorism and
discussion about national identity cards
or facial recognition systems shouldn't
be left to the government or governor
ridge or
attorney general Ashcroft or the Joint
Chiefs of Staff were Larry Ellison alone
this is a conversation that speaks to
fundamental issues of security and
freedom and it would be unpatriotic not
to engage in a vigorous explanation
exploration and debate about these
issues forth if the vigilance associated
with 911 recedes and I for one hope that
it doesn't because complacency has
already led two national trauma and
resumed complacency will only I fear
lead to national tragedy even if
vigilance recedes the underlying trend
of data collection and analysis by both
business and government will not these
trains have left the station the
question for society is whether we
choose as a society to make sure that
the train has a conductor and that
someone responsible is at the switch
fifth technology is way ahead of
government or society or even businesses
understanding of that technology its
implications or its potential
consequences this again and to repeat is
accelerating irrespective of 911 or the
war on terrorism so we're faced with a
misalignment society and certainly
government is incapable of fully
understanding technology or its
consequences in the context of an a
genuine national and international
crisis we're desperately trying to
harness that technology to combat
genuine and palpable threats but in the
process we may be accelerating the
distance that divides our understanding
and control of technology with the reach
and unintended consequences of its
application I don't mean to trivialize
especially after Jeff's moving words but
perhaps a constructive way of
illustrating the dilemma is to remind
ourselves of one of the many lessons of
enron and that is that the business that
Enron eventually became was basically
unmanageable even by the people who
created it managers couldn't manage
auditors couldn't detect Woods couldn't
understand analysts couldn't assess
risks
government couldn't regulate it's a
sobering and cautionary tale with many
lessons some might be relevant for
discussion and debate tonight one is
that we know less than we think we know
secondly it's vitally important to
continuously raise questions that
clarify our understanding and thirdly in
areas of uncertainty especially where
developments outpace comprehension
government must play a stronger and more
assertive not a weaker or more compliant
role government may not be adequately
sophisticated but it's our last best
hope for ensuring that rules are
established and our family and
vigorously enforced okay so where does
that leave us in terms of Big Brother
and big business privacy security and
the war on terrorism let me conclude
with five observations first in my
opinion we clearly need to employ more
and better information based technology
and especially in terms of coordination
between federal state and local law
enforcement and first responder networks
such as hospitals in the CDC let's be
honest about this government is way
behind the market in doing this right
and it needs to catch up fast this isn't
a question of more big brother but of a
more confident less Keystone cop
government one that we desperately need
either we get this right not just at
airports or a train stations and border
crossings but at sea ports where 12
million containers come and go every
year either we get this right or the
next Mohamed Atta will do us wrong next
time with likely much more lethal and
devastating consequences second the
rules that govern the new networks need
to be explicit and much more transparent
government needs to set and enforce
these rules and we need to avoid carving
out any regulatory black holes similar
to what Enron deliberately engineered
for itself that the chain is only as
strong as its weakest link government
and regulators need to check its
strength test its vulnerabilities and
safeguard its compliance with the rule
that society sets through its government
third I don't think we should bash the
Larry Ellison's of the business world we
desperately need their talent and
technology let's encourage more not
fewer of them to take a place at the
table it's the ingenuity that's found
largely in the private sector not in
government that holds the key to
technological innovations that may
overcome some of the most devious clever
and certainly lethal threats the world
has ever countenanced let's not shoot
the medium or the messenger Ellison
Gerstner welsh gates let's encourage
them rather than squirrel that heap them
with scorn as I recall the 911 attack
might have been thwarted if our
government hadn't been constructed into
hardened bureaucratic silos while people
in the private sector know how to
overcome these silos and make things
work first we're loyal envisions should
have been worrying us long ago probably
even well before 1984 which was 18 years
ago it's too late to put the horse back
in the barn but we need to construct a
new Corral that can contains the
capacities that we need with the privacy
and protections that we want and we as
Americans of course one at all where we
can also lose it all this is hard work
and we need to get on with it rather
than spending too much time lamenting
the world that never was finally I
mentioned in passing that 911 changes or
should have changed everything including
capitalism while the future of
capitalism is referred to in the flyer
about this panel that the questions I
was sent in advance didn't return to the
topic let me use my last 60 seconds to
do so because one of the big lessons of
911 in my opinion is
that business and capitalism itself
needs to also change and recalibrate
some of its most basic assumptions in a
word I believe we need a new capitalism
one that's driven by purpose as well as
profits one that provides value for
society as well as value for
shareholders the new capitalism won't
alone bring peace to the Middle East or
wipe out al Qaeda but a new capitalism
that extends economic opportunity to
some of the four billion marginalized
people in this world who don't
participate in the economic mainstream
as we know it this kind of capitalism
with a conscience and a purpose can go a
long way to making people feel that they
that there are dreams worth pursuing
beyond martyrdom fundamentalism or
fanaticism so to be provocative I'll end
with the assertion that despite the
dangers what's needed most right now is
not less big government but smarter big
government not less big business but
more principled big business and without
smarter better and more ethical
government and business the freedoms and
the Fourth Amendment rights were also
concerned about maybe put in a lot
greater jeopardy than if big government
and big business failed to step up to
the plate thank
cherry cherry bourbon thank you it's a
for inviting me and it is a pleasure to
be here of course we have a significant
problem of terrorism that needs to be
addressed and we need more efficient
government and we need a better
government and everyone should step up
to the plate I do not find that
provocative I find that common sensical
the issue for us is whether since nine
eleven the question has been posed
whether in order to take on terrorism
and to thwart it and to investigate it
we have to give up our open society or
our privacy rights the previous speaker
but point is that you know the horses
out of the barn let me just take you
back to the day before nine eleven
happen the debate in this country and
the polls and the facts were that
privacy was insignificant jeopardy
because of several things high
technology we are living in a networked
world in order to do business in order
to live our lives we have to turn over
more and more information to the private
sector and to government they have vast
databases on us and the debate before
nine eleven and it's beginning again is
how do you strike the balance between
our efficient business and the ability
of commerce to succeed but also our
rights to know what information is being
collected about us how it's being held
whoo it's being disclosed to and for
what purposes it ought to be transparent
to the consumer that does not seem to
and I don't think making it transparent
to the consumer stands in the way of the
war on terrorism there the argument that
we may have to give up some of our
privacy at the airports we're all you
know taking off our shoes and going
through the three lines and standing and
our bags are being checked and no one's
waging a gigantic protest over that
because it seems reasonable and when
it's reasonable and it's explained to us
we go along the issue however is is when
proposals are made which which may not
be explained which may take and I want
to refer to what happened after nine
eleven with respect to government power
the horse was already I'm going to get
this metaphor all backwards but before
nine eleven the government had on the
record and stated that it had
significant national security power it
has been granted special authority to do
intelligence investigations under less
than probable cause standards using a
criminal investigation to keep the
information secret to conduct it with a
there's a secret special court that
looks at wiretaps and national security
cases there are foreign intelligence
surveillance guidelines the intelligence
and law enforcement has operated under a
whole set of rules hammered out 20 years
ago following the disclosures of
watergate that something we needed to
strengthen our intelligence capability
but we have to strike a balance and get
our intelligence agencies to focus not
on political beliefs or unlawful
activity but to focus on crime they had
thousands and thousands and thousands of
files it wasn't serving national
security they weren't preventing
weathermen and they weren't preventing
student bombings and they weren't what
they were doing was investigating
vietnam war protesters under very broad
and vague authorities that had been
granted during the Cold War every it was
a whole set of powers that had started
out saying prevent terrorism prevent
communism it ended up investigating
Martin Luther King and disrupt a threat
to our national security became the
disruption of Martin Luther King and the
southern leadership civil rights
conference things had gone awry and
there was an effort to set it back
straight but what happened was that the
national security was given great power
to investigate and privacy was put in
that balance and in my view the whole
history of legislative efforts and
reform efforts has been that there you
do not trade off privacy and national
security you balance them because if you
don't get it right you are liable to
have over intrusive investigation which
may not be very efficient yet you've got
files on everyone but you can't tell you
have so many investigations that the
real bad fish get right through the net
and that happened during the Watergate
era and ah so it is striking that
balance when 911 came law enforcement
went to the hill and said we need to
change all of these laws we need more
access to business records we need to
lower the standard for wiretapping
individuals they have authority to talk
terrorists including us terrorists
suspected terrorists they had under
surveillance most of the people that
were
though that had come into the country
including the the person who is now
facing trial for taking flying lessons
and learning to fly but not to land they
had them under surveillance the issue
wasn't a law that was standing in their
way they just didn't communicate between
I NS and the FBI and CIA that
information they didn't share there is a
great bureaucratic bottle that goes on
between the CIA and FBI which I don't
want to go into too much detail but
there are more bureaucratic struggles
between our law enforcement agencies and
maybe Keystone cop law enforcement then
there is a lack of authority to
investigate and to pretend of national
security threats but nevertheless in six
weeks Congress passed and change the
standards for intelligence
investigations they can now conduct
criminal investigations under an
authority where it's lower than probable
cause for a wiretap and it's secret it
is never disclosed to you unlike a law
enforcement wiretap it's and we're not
talking about you got to think about
this is a top of your home a secret
search of your home a secret search of
your residents a secret search of your
of your business which is never
disclosed they change the law on records
access financial credit medical not
simply to get access to records of
persons suspected of being engaged in
terrorist activity but any record which
may be relevant to a terrorist
investigation that under a very that
it's relevant that's a very almost
non-existent standard and what have they
been consciously going after is
information not simply of terrorists but
anyone who may be in association with
them they're looking at if you live in
an apartment building they want the
information on every
on that apartment building they are
doing extensive data mining which is
gathering up a lot of information and
trying to make connections for
intelligence purposes that they might be
able to find that someone on an airplane
who looks suspicious there might be
several people from Capitol Hill and
he's from Capitol Hill and they all they
all ought to be taken off and their
shoes taken off and and investigate it
they're not sure what they're doing but
they have great authority to look at
this information we think that they went
far beyond of anything that they
justified on the record the simple
requests that we made a civil
libertarians my testified three times in
earrings was that you go through the
process of marking up bills going
through the legislative process having
hearings having a floor debate offering
amendments they absolutely
short-circuited that process and said
that anyone who was in that way or
trying to exercise the simple procedure
cars was aiding and abetting terrorism
and they've said on the record that they
were more interested not simply in
getting authority but using this as an
occasion to take a whole wish list out
of the closet that they wanted to pass
and the pass it now and I can and and
state it on that record and they want
more they from the day of 911 to today
there has been no documentation on the
record that there is any relationship
between the authority on the books at
any of it hampered any investigation of
any terror suspect they can't point to a
rule on the book that said it was too
strict and therefore it hampered our
hands they are shifting the blame to
privacy laws which are absolutely
inadequate and saying that's the problem
when it's really a bureaucratic and
intelligence failure of mass proportions
which they do not want to discuss on the
record we do not have
a constitutional right to privacy when
it comes to information that's not in
your home the information and banks in
these networks on the internet is not
covered by a strong privacy regime it is
absolutely up for grabs and government
can have access to it that is the way it
is so we have already traded our privacy
the question is we'd like to see more
oversight to it to determine whether it
has done anything to improve or make
more efficient or our intelligence
capability or whether we ought to
rewrite that balance I don't think I've
got a prayer of doing that or civil
libertarians right now and also by the
way stop the debate over having some
simple rules over disclosure about what
businesses do with your commercial
information that legislation stopped in
its tracks business is now off the hook
because it's the the the threat of
national security has taken that and
they're they're happily free stopping
their self regulatory efforts stopping
advertising that they're really working
on your privacy every day cutting back
their budgets for privacy protection and
their self regulatory efforts that's all
being sacrificed I don't think that's
justified what most troubling is that in
granting new powers to our intelligence
agencies to investigate to collect
business records to to to conduct
wiretaps on of anyone who may have
unquote unauthorized access to a
computer they did not establish an
oversight systems so that Congress is
systematically looking at what what law
enforcement is doing about these issues
one minute there needs to be we may need
a national ID card we may need new forms
of authentication but you need to have a
dialogue between the business community
policy
makers privacy advocates and the public
and that has to be transparent and open
that does not happen when you pass
legislation in the middle of the night
and when you and when you if you say
I'll give you business records but the
Attorney General says but no gun records
that's off-limits what's the rationale
that's running through that we're
lacking a rationale we're lacking any
systemic understanding of what they're
trying to do in changing the law I think
that the balance is not construct and I
think we have a lot to debate before we
take any further steps to loosen
Authority or further erode our privacy
and I say that in with my major goal as
all of us to us have a more safe and
secure society that protects our open
values thank
I think what I'm going to suggest is
that before we go to audience questions
I'm going to invite each panelist to ask
one question of another panelist and get
a little dialogue going on the panel and
then throw it open Jeff out what struck
me when Jerry spoke the most and I lost
count but what struck me was the
constant repetition when refer to
government as they it's always about
they is about protecting all rights and
I must tell you that from my own point
of view you know I remember if you look
back at our Constitution and Declaration
of Independence the languages of we is
we are the people it is our government
these are our officials and what
troubles me in the remarks is I hope we
have not come a point in our history
where you believe that the government is
they and we are we and that this isn't a
common enterprise we're collectively the
government the government our elected
officials aren't trying to protect this
country against a real incredible threat
and that we have the power as a free
society the people who are our
representatives to be sensitive to and
transparent to the issues of civil
liberties so my question is do you
really believe it is it is we and they
know I do not but government has a
tendency of also saying we and they and
believing that that that they can make
these decisions without a significant
public debate and involvement by the way
we are I am because of the way that this
was done the way that this legislation
passed I am I am driven back to the Bill
of Rights the gentle of clause of the
constitution we the people the Commerce
Clause we get down to the bottom of that
but there is also the Bill of Rights and
it was a we they and there was a great
there is a a suspicion and a right
suspicion that runs through american
society of unchecked power and
government and that has been
a healthy thing in America and it it is
attention that's there in the Bill of
Rights Congress shall make no law and
that is speaking on behalf people I
don't distinguish myself from the
government but when but when many people
are not consulted in those there is no
consultative process I I am a bit
unhappy with the way it went down that's
all I jeff has struck me listening to
you and the poignant tale that you
experienced having started the day at
the windows in the world that you become
an instant expert and that we'd be smart
to tap your insights and expertise not
only about buildings and building
security but other generic insights that
you undoubtedly have formulated about
other security vulnerabilities and other
smart intelligent and non-intrusive
steps that we need to take to secure our
entire community you know fight while I
was thinking about it I was so saying to
myself you know the same reason that you
say you can't the Constitution protects
us totally the Supreme Court in earlier
Stacy you say you also can't cry fire in
a theater you know when there's no
firearm you just can't do that either
and we have had intrusions on our
liberties need for example there are
lost our books where people have
committed crimes against children they
were identifying the community protect
the community but that's right or wrong
I don't know but the issue that you
raised before is the issue i think at
the heart of it that we as a society
will have to decide how much we are
prepared to to give up our freedoms to
particulars personal safety and i'll
tell you what strikes me every day that
we believe that the worst is behind us
if you ask people outside lower
manhattan it's better it's different in
midtown if you go you know to New Jersey
as Betty my our son lives in Phoenix and
it's different there and people in
California I think there is
beginning to the feeling of a mood that
this happened to downtown Manhattan it
happened once it was horrible it was
awful but thank God it's behind us and
we'll you know we are free of it I
personally don't happen to share the
view and and what I have you know spent
considerable time as you as you
mentioned is trying to in a very real
commercial sense help to reset the
balance because if you come into my
building you know I feel a sense of
responsibility for your safety and I
would set the line probably further than
somebody else would to provide a safe
environment and I'll tell you something
next time you go to a movie theater and
you're in a dark room and there's 500
people there you tell me how many people
in that room you think are carrying a
handgun and i'll bet you without knowing
it there's ten to twenty percent of the
people in almost any theater in this
country today sitting with a handgun
half them which you're illegal now if
you feel safe and secure that's fine
timeout cat meow respond well that
figures I'm saying to you you know it's
there's a question I think that we off
to face it's very real impractical that
I am I have fought for civil liberties
my whole life but I understand that the
world got different for me on the
eleventh and is different for everybody
in this room and if we are prepared to
accept a society that's fine I'm if we
as a society agree as a majority we're
prepared to accept that threat to us I
think it's fine i just think we all need
to participate it and we need to set the
line together Jerry let me respond to
that I mean yesterday I hope you read
the paper not only did did you have the
the bombing in our attorney general hat
authorized the Solicitor General arguing
to Supreme Court cases that to reverse
the government's position that the
Second Amendment does not guarantee the
right of everyone to have a hand none
they now are taking position the Second
Amendment protects that they really said
that you can look at your credit records
but not we will not allow you to search
the gun owners
database get real is this government
fighting terrorism or are they being
selectively looking at certain things
one of the reasons that there's a lot of
big business opposition to a national ID
card I oppose it on privacy groans but
there is a lot of big business
opposition because they rely on foreign
workers foreign software designers and
so on and so the right wing said no
national ID card and that was taken
right off the table not debated in the
Patriot Act look I look I think we are
very schizophrenic as a society if you
are an employer you can't ask anybody
marital status age any number of
questions you can't ask but I am Telling
You here's where I side with you if I
have that card and I swipe in the
building I know more about that person
walking in than a person who is employs
them to me that's utterly bizarre and I
don't get it I mean it's it's it's the
most inconsistent thing the world to me
that I can look at you won't employ you
can't find out three things about you
but I can let you know I can walk into
building get everything every bit of
information on you just by swiping a
card through it now that's where I grew
with you it that makes absolutely no
sense to me and if somebody can explain
it to me I'd like to raise their hand
and do it well I think before we go to
the audience let me take the product
with a chair for a moment I think this
really gets to the nub of it that there
are wild inconsistencies in the belief
that we have a mirror as Americans about
privacy and security that are somewhat
inconsistent with each other and there
are wild inconsistencies in how this
particular government is going about
trying to protect our security in some
respects I think going too far in other
respects as in the Solicitor General's
of testimony on handguns not going
nearly far enough I am a card-carrying
member of the ACLU and I am probably in
a tiny minority of ACLU members who
think it would be a good thing if we had
a national ID card because for me the
issue is who has access to the data and
how it's utilized rather than whether
it's collected because it's already
collected it's collected if you apply
for a driver's license its collected if
you apply for a passport
it's collected if you apply for a credit
card your data already reposes in dozens
of databases public sector and private
sector the issue is whether it is to be
utilized for certain purposes without a
judge signing off on a search warrant
and until recently I was fairly self
confident in holding that position that
if the government had an adequate set of
safeguards I wasn't afraid of a national
ID card then I realized that right now
the government is John Ashcroft so with
that and I think although I very much
believe in We the People just from my
personal point of view John Ashcroft is
very much are they and I think something
similar effect
Jefferson when when he was fighting for
the for the Bill of Rights that this is
a democratic government and yet police
agencies whether in totalitarian
governments or in democratic governments
have this Achilles heel where they tend
to view rights as inconveniences and
obstacles and it is very much a
balancing who would like to have the
first question from the audience yes
ma'am um hi I'm Cindy Shriver from the
Columbia Journalism scroll um my
question is how what is being done now
to link government database government
agency databases and from there how far
away is it from linking those databases
to private sector databases like airline
passenger lists well I can I'll take a
shot at it there is a from the last nine
months under governor Ridge there's been
an effort to draft a national critical
infrastructures strategy including the
idea of a Fed net where the government
would be connect itself all up together
and link all of its databases it's it's
it's fallen on the ground that no one
quite knows how to do it there's a lot
of opposition from government agencies
and from also from the private sector
one of the one of the the there are real
turf battles between agencies over
information there are even concerns for
example if you talk to a many large
corporations where when the government
says will come in and protect your
computer systems and your networks
they're worried about the vulnerability
created by letting the government in
because they have less trust of the
government and the Hansons and the
ability of them to sell information to a
terrorist that it creates security
problems of its own so there's not
there's not it's
out there who's supposed to do which job
many of a lot of data is is distributed
databases are available now simply
because the internet makes it so but but
the the internet will can't is a step
away because it's still a web page
doesn't tell you what another web page
means and that technology is being
developed by the world wide web
consortium which is doing standards for
that and I think we're several years
away from the ability of a very
transparently for agencies to link these
databases together that's a long answer
to say it's not there yet yes this
question is for mr. Warren my name is
Michelle Karam i'm a student at Columbia
Business School you mentioned earlier
that the current security systems and
buildings are mostly a sham and don't
provide any safety you talked a little
bit about how seven world trade center
you're building a stronger building but
short of building a stronger building
which obviously we can't do for all the
buildings that currently exist what
sacrifices of privacy would even be
necessary in order for greater safety to
occur were sufficient first let me be
clear I'm not suggesting that everything
we're doing is a sham I mean I that
overstates the position I'm suggesting
that today I think the general trend of
thinking is that providing a perception
of security will give you a high
standard of security and I just
challenge the assumption one thing we
are trying to do in terms of the
building is to intercept people at an
earlier at the earliest possible moment
that we could do harm to building right
now you're in most buildings before
anybody challenges who you are and
identifies who you are it's a question
of an issue if you go down if you're in
Midtown in the next few days walk past
the Deutsche Bank building which is on
fifty-second between fifth and six and
you'll see that they have a table
outside the building because they made a
decision that they want to screen people
before they enter a building most people
do the screening inside a building
most people do the screen the building
to stop you from going upstairs which
says in effect that the lobby is at risk
and if somebody wants to do something in
the lobby it's fair game now I'll let me
tell you make it practical because I
think that's what we should deal with
any of any man today is wearing a jacket
pneus in this audience can carry about
50 pounds of explosives on that person
without being detected a suitcase can
carry about 100 pounds and in wintertime
you could probably count hundred pounds
of explosive and ability without being
detected so the question is you know we
prepare it again just to to say we want
a screen like we do at airports people
who are bringing you know either
themselves or packaged into a building
as a way of screening things before they
enter a building you know it's a
decision where where's the point at
which we want to have the place where we
do it and at that point again what kind
of information we want an individual do
we want to know who you are so we can
quickly run a data check giving the
example at Rockefeller Center during the
Christmas season we had about 800 trucks
a day trying into the system and what we
had thought about doing was getting a
scanner to check license plates to check
it against police records immediately to
see way to install the vehicle now we
didn't do a full of practical reasons
but I'd ask you the same question do you
think it's appropriate you know to
inconvenience everybody to screen and
know who is entering a building and
during the loading dock you know has
access to it it's it's a question of
where you want to set the line and I
think we'll decided collectively and
then we will accept you the benefits of
the burdens of what we've done my name
is Georgia Tech I am a student at
Teachers College Columbia University
this is a question to mr. Byrne Berman
in the wake of last year's anthrax
scares there seems to be a push to give
governors and state level officials
vastly expanded powers to rule by decree
I mean to seize property and may gain
access to communications with not with
no need to consult with third parties
and that this kind of initiative seems
benign in advan certainly well-meant but
i think the fiat resists that
once an emerges emergency is declared
these officials might start wielding
dictatorial powers to the detriment of
civil liberties my question is how can
we ensure that these seemingly Albin I
and maybe less obtrusive measures will
not be abused well it is a very
significant question because Georgetown
University just did a study there are 20
or more states amending the wiretap
statutes and creating anti-terrorism
operations of their own and then every
country is also there is the tendency
whether it's on the merits or not to
duplicate and and to copy and say they
got the power we ought to have the power
and and there is a rationale I mean
things happen at home there's a lot of
discontent always about the
unwillingness of the feds to share
information with the states and it's a
favorite plot of every detective novel
you know the battle between FBI agents
and the state cops that so there I do
not know of any way except federal
preemption of state law but that's not
going to happen in this area there's
just citizens in different states are
going to have to watch those statutes I
believe that we're on the we're in the
middle of it's a wave and the wave is
going to go and many laws and privacy
laws are going to be weakened the issue
right now is it has accepted if you're a
poor Muslim in the
southern community you're in trouble but
the these laws tend to be narrowly
applied for a while and then something
else happens and they take on another
life of their own and it's we haven't
for example a good political battle in
this country over Israel and Palestine
and what to do in the Middle East and
Iraq that leads to a peace movement and
people who then is aiding and abetting
terrorism and who's investigating whom
and who is collecting files on whom I
think is a nightmare scenario from a
privacy point of view but it hasn't
happened yet these things don't happen
overnight but the but the statutory
regime the walls that I think were put
up 20 years ago to try and and and get
our our investigative agencies not
focusing on political activity but
focusing on criminal activity and even
serious intelligent investigations even
if they're doing it today they have far
more much more discretion sitting on the
books that they can exercise and that's
a problem up here my name is Archie
comic so that i'm a student up here
columbia journalism school my question
would be mr. Bowman and I'd like to know
what is the media's role when they see
the conflict between national security
and civil liberties it is a very
disappointing I'm very disappointed in
the media we they they tend to to cover
what's hot and if its conflict we try to
get the media to cover what changes in
the law we're being proposed of in the
patriot act just as a matter of
informing the public and having
a debate about it's a very difficult not
that it's easy to understand but they
were more interested in waiting till the
ball past and then suddenly you become a
national celebrity you're on crossfire
and your ear on the news hour and you
anytime I'm on all those shows from my
point of view that means we've we've
really taken it we've really lost
something and we're there to bleed for
for ratings and so I don't think the
press played a very good reporting role
they did not explain these issues well
they didn't have a very much lead time
since the legislation passed in six
weeks what are in for sure why they
didn't do a good job well they would
have had to do a lot of work beyond
sound bites a national security law is
not is not easy and in fact the
institutional memory of Congress which
the we there was a I have the gray hair
i was there 20 years ago working on
these statutes it was like going around
there was suddenly a call out for all
these geriatrics civil liberties
advocates and intelligence experts to
come back to Congress and explaining
them what they were doing because they
didn't know that the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act didn't
apply to foreigners it apply to foreign
intelligence connections to Americans in
the United States so very hard for
Congress understand that they that they
didn't know why they were acting and we
are still we are producing an analysis
now which we are going to release in
January to tell so that Congress for the
first time I believe we'll find out what
they passed let me just interject a
NASCAR a question of your a proponent
of civically responsible business
business government collaboration where
is business in this civil liberties
national security balance and me it
seems to me on the one hand it's a
business opportunity to develop and sell
all kinds of new technologies and new
equipment to government on the other
hand business is concerned about its own
proprietary commercial secrets not being
invaded on the third hand businesses
trying to strike a balance between not
terrifying consumers that if you do
business with somebody your privacy is
going to be invaded but on the other
hand being able to exercise commerce so
where is business isn't it on all three
counts so you answered your own question
but shed some more light up no no why
don't we go back to the kids no let me
give it with me let me let me know let
him go ahead ah great I there are a lot
of that lot of the business community
sees a security as an important
procurement opportunity and a chance to
and they want and that's good I mean
that means that they're exercising their
ingenuity to come out and and and try
and develop I got Larry Ellison of
Oracle so that I've got a great idea
card idea the government looked at and
said not really good idea where II go
back to the drawing boards they didn't
they didn't adopt it we do need a debate
between different proposals the the
driver license people want to turn the
driver's license into an ID system it's
a it's a it sounds transparently
interesting except that there are so
many human just think about when you go
down and get your driver's license how
many places you can get them how many
human vulnerabilities are going to be in
a state-run system I don't care so you
know it's not going to cost much you
just get a bribe a few people to put
different pictures on different IDs and
load it up
I think business is trying to to put
that they are working they come to us
and try and engage in they are trying to
build better locks and keys of for the
infrastructure they want to they want to
improve security but they also are do
not want on the government to overreach
and and impose enormous cost of doing
business on them IRA business
historically has distrusted government
just as most Americans have distrusted
their government ever since don't tread
on me or live free or die but I think we
all noticed all 285 million Americans
that when the World Trade Center
collapse no one called Jack Welch or
Bill Gates they were looking for their
government and I think business leaders
are looking to their government to take
care of national security and I think
most business leaders acknowledge that
the pendulum has swung too far so they
want their government to be competent
they want to be capable they want it to
be a proactive they want it to be
technologically competent and I think
they want to help as most of us want to
help our government and our society
stave off something that would even be
more horrific than 911 I think business
doesn't it business is not monolithic
just as our nation and its politics is
not monolithic I don't think there's a
conspiracy of big business to make a
buck here and I think you're absolutely
right that most companies are concerned
about having differentiated products
that don't put them in the same network
and system as everybody else's product
so I think they're about as confused as
the rest of us let me tell you about
business
law that's not on the books called the
law of unintended consequences and would
take you back to nineteen forty seven or
about that time where technology was was
developed to to aim of cannons on tanks
and the concept behind the technology is
more daddy you got it to the computer
the more you could name the tank and hit
a target the next step for that
technology was in supermarkets where
they use the technology basically to see
what was on the shelf so that we can
restock the shelf then somebody figured
out what's the next way use that and now
here's what the law of unintended
consequences came in it wasn't the
question to figure out what was on the
shelf it was a question of figuring out
who was picking the material up off the
shelf and what we can learn about the
consumer so the barcode on the on the on
to everything you buy in the market the
purpose of it ultimately is not to track
what's on the show but to track you
that's what it's there for that's how it
evolved it started initially the way I
told you it evolved the steps that I
gave to you so it's really not a
question about the technology it's I
think what you said before it's what we
want to use it for it's there we know
it's not even to believe it's not there
and it's very sophisticated it's about
our values and what we want to
accomplish the society and that we
participate in the decisions which
affect our lives let me thank you let me
suggest let's take several comments or
questions from the audience and now
let's have a quick concluding round from
the pound yeah I have a question that's
related to the question that was asked
previously just now um we're engaging
these kind of debates in this room and
policy circles etc and I'm wondering in
your opinion how well-informed you think
the average American is about these
issues of civil liberties and national
ID card and all these debate debates are
happening and what you think can be done
to increase an understanding of what's
going on so that the person knows how it
will directly I was trying to make the
point earlier that I think this all
precedes 911 and we've all been asleep
at the switch for a long time and
understanding how pervasive these issues
are in terms of privacy due process
equal protection information and like
and I think there's a huge role here for
the media to play
in identifying and skeptically looking
at exactly how much the world has
changed chase manhattan bank knows a lot
more about you than your government and
your healthcare provider probably knows
a lot more about you than Chase
Manhattan Bank these are important and
significant issues unrelated to 911 that
we as Americans are not engaged with
their difficult issues their intractable
issues DNA is another issue all sorts of
ethical implications we have a very
sophisticated DNA database it's almost
scientifically perfect but it only
applies to those who have been involved
in the criminal justice system there's a
huge racial bias in that sample what do
we think about that as Americans what do
you think Thomas Jefferson would think
about his life being explored 200 years
after his death by virtue his DNA I mean
what do you think he would say if you
were here today in case to comment he'd
say I'm not going to be President
how would you suggest that we as
citizens proceed now to re-establish the
Liberty that has been hastily taken away
by the Patriot Act let's hold off on
that answer and get cut I'm sure mr.
Berman would like to start okay what
kind of links into that question
actually it's more furro mr. Jackson and
mr. Warren because I think I know where
mr. Berman stands but obviously at some
level you need you do need like
oversight and you need debate as both of
you gentlemen have said that you do need
a debate about these things and need to
figure out what the playoffs are but my
question is in terms of like the
political climate yes we're more aware
of like security and things you said
we've been asleep at the wheel and this
has taken people by surprise and so that
aspect of the debate has been kind of
catapulted into the spotlight but my
question is do you think that the
political consequences of like our state
of warfare basically we're in war in
Afghanistan probably going to be in war
in Iraq what impact do you think that is
going to have on the political debate
and you worry in the future that it
might stifle the kind of debates that
we're having now because I mean to link
this back to Big Brother and I hope
haven't misremembered my all well but in
1984 part of the system was the constant
state of warfare undermining domestic
criticism so I'd like to put that to you
two gentlemen and see if you even that's
not a worry now whether it could become
a worry let's get two more from the
floor and then let's go around the panel
at have everybody respond yeah my
question is that as we navigate between
civil liberties and security it seems
like a lot of the regulations have been
coming out of the justice department in
the executive branch of government the
Bush administration had been accused of
acting laterally internationally in the
past and are they now acting
unilaterally domestically and is that
for good or for worse what one more from
the floor my name is Natasha kresna of
my question is mostly to mr. Wharton you
have mentioned the fact that you can
walk around and go into most buildings
in Midtown
without having to show your idea or
anything and that some companies now
will put a table out checking what I
wanted to bring up is the fact that it's
not just the identification that we
worry about its identifying people who
want to do something bad and isn't it
true in fact that the people that were
on those planes on September 11th were
had to be identified before they got on
the plains and it is the link between
the ill will and the personal
identification that we were missing and
how can we go about actually
establishing a quick let's let these
last two folks have been standing
patiently and then we can go to the
fallon one thing that i think is missing
from this debate is the fact that there
was a breakdown in the intelligence
community group so house of the
government should be allowed to collect
more information when they haven't been
able to do anything to protect us with
what they've already got good quick time
that's I think I said I one last
question and then let's go around this
question is also from mr. warden I'm
talking about security as you say if you
put on a jacket you can hide anything
all it's going to take is one bombing
similar to what we have in Israel and a
theater or a public place and
everybody's going to be clamoring we're
not doing enough we're not doing a knife
well I commute from Brooklyn are you
going to search me on the way to the F
train are you going to search me when I
go into the grocery store I think that
it's inevitable that we cannot supply
that level of security and it turns back
to what the lady before me said it turns
to intent and it turns then to searching
what my thoughts are and coming back to
saying this person is the one that we
want to search and then it turns into
thought control because you're going to
be saying these people believe a certain
way we can collect that information
through the laws we've already passed we
caused enough trouble for them by
searching them often enough they won't
have a job they won't get to work on
time and pretty soon you don't go to
those meetings you don't make those
discussions I think that's the slippery
slope we have we can't be secure I
believe and I'd like your comments on
that
okay in this in this world yeah I'm not
suggesting any of the answer but let me
tell you how a terrorist is effective
they make you afraid of everything you
do in your life that's routine by
constantly changing the rules of
engagement and you don't change the
rules of engagement change every day so
as I said before and Israel it was the
first floor it's the third floor it is a
plane it could be a car it could be the
tunneling be trained I'm not suggesting
the answer I'm merely posing the
question and we will decide based upon
how this war and terrorism evolves and
how much it affects our lives what were
willing to tolerate to provide a safe
and secure society and we won't know
that until we you know we until we go
further down the road and you know I
share the view that we have been
unpredictably fortunate in the last
seven months that nothing else has
happened and I suggest we're in the eye
of the hurricane and when we on the
other side of it and something happens
again we will be faced with the most
horrible decisions in society is where
we want to place the rules and I'm not
suggesting the answer i'm merely posing
the question thank you for quick
observations i think this kind of
discussion is the basic business of
democracy and we need to encourage more
of it secondly we're a very binary
culture we have a very short attention
span and I'm afraid that we'll lose
interest I don't think our leaders are
venal enough to ever sustained more to
distract attention from domestic
politics I think we have enough
safeguards to ensure that doesn't occur
but i think the greater danger is that
once we quote unquote win a war will go
back to business as usual third Jonah
has a new book out called the paradox of
American power America is the strongest
society since the Roman Empire but
curiously it can't go it alone and in
fact the more it acts unilaterally the
weaker it becomes and I think the
observation that American exceptionalism
and American unilateralism is exercised
not only in our global
and foreign policy but also at home is
an interesting observation and one
that's worth dwelling on finally you
know it's our government as as Jeff said
earlier and it has been entrusted for
lack of anyone else to entrust with
enormous power and authority I think it
needs to use this power and authority
very vigorously very wisely and the
press and others have a very important
role in ensuring that it doesn't abuse
that authority and the concerns that
jerry has raised repeatedly will lead if
he's right and if government is now
abusing that authority or not not
needing that authority it will lead to
another binary reaction which will lead
to the law of unintended consequences
kicking in yet again so this is our time
it's our set of issues and I think we
need to make sure that our government
acts responsibly I think that the that's
it is a watershed time and it's a it's
important that these issues be covered
in the media it's important that that
citizens even if you don't understand
all of the dimensions if you care about
the privacy balance raise it with your
your memory Congress because right now
they are just terrified of doing
anything that might if it goes wrong is
going to you know if a terrorist attack
they're going to be playing for it
they're going to be thrown out of office
they don't they they don't they need
some backbone the the other thing I
worry about when I particularly the ID
card and issues like that were where you
start you say all we need to do is
identify people at airports and then it
begins you say well what about deadbeat
dads and then there are crooks and then
there are how much what information goes
into it and it begins to become a large
potentially very intrusive technology
and I come back to terrorists terrorists
this was very different kind of
terrorist act terrorism really thrives
on trying to undermine the legitimacy of
the government by taking acts that that
make it overreact and undermine the
legitimacy within a community no one
could say that this wasn't this is an
act of war because it didn't build any
sympathy from anybody for anything
except maybe in a Muslim community but
if our government over reacts over a
period of time and raises doubts about
its commitment to open society or or or
creates things that that that chill
speech or privacy without laying a
justification for it will play to that's
what terrorists royally love that's
their aim and the undermine if they
undermine our commitment to open society
they really will have one and we just
can't give them that victory and I am
what spent all day last point working
with the National Security Council on
I'm not a wee they we are trying to yell
and scream at each other at a certain
point but we are trying to work together
to try and develop a national strategy
that addresses open the society issues
as well as national security so the
debate goes on participate at least
express your concern and the press can
do an awful lot then thank you all for
participating
I say